من الولايات المتحده الى قهرمان مرعش وصل
السوريه سين واصدقائه في فريق ايرثي كونه
ياسين مع اقربائه الناجين من الزلزال
والمقيمين في تركيا
يجوبون الحدائق والاماكن العامه لتقديم
مساعدات عاجله ليست للجميع بل للاكثر حاجه
كما يقول ياسين انا ببحث عن جد محتاجه عن
جد اللي ما وصلت للمساعدات عن جد احنا
موجودين لهون الها نحن جينا مبادره مالنا
منظمه والان منظمه مالها ربحيه فقرارنا
بايدنا بنقدر نروح وين ما بدنا في عنا
المنظمات اللي اشتركت معنا هي السيريال
الرغيف
مرسي فهي كانت اعطيتنا الخيارات انه نحن
نختار وين نروح وننفذ مشروعنا للناس
الاماس حاجه لانه في مشاريع للاسف صاير
فيها اسراف زياده عن اللزوم يعني بتلاقي
انه المناطق الفقيره فيها اقل اهتمام من
المناطق اللي عليها الاعلام والمناطق
الغنيه حاول ياسين الدخول الى سوريا لكنه
لم يستطع يقول انه مع اصدقائه استطاع ان
يرسل مساعداتهم الى الداخل السوري عبر
جمعيات خيريه بينما يقوم هو شخصيا
بتوزيعها في تركيا
ما اقوم به هنا يقع ضمن مجال عملي في
بلادي حيث اعمل في التدريب الطبي وتقديم
الاغاثه في حالات الطوارئ وقد شعرت
بالسعاده عندما تلقيت اتصالا هاتفيا من
صديقي ياسين وتمكني من المجيء الى هنا
ولتقديم الدعم للاتراك والسوريين
المتضررين من الزلزال يخطط الفريق السوري
الامريكي التطوعي لان يجوب كافه المحافظات
التركيه العشر المتضرره لايصال اكبر قدر
ممكن من المساعدات بجهود ذاتيه
اكثر من مليونين نازح جعل من الصعب توزيع
كافه المساعدات عليهم خصوصا الذين لا
يتواجدون في المخيمات الرئيسيه ما دفع
ياسين وفريقه من امريكا الى بذل هذه
المجهودات التي قد تخفف من معاناه هؤلاء
النازحين عبد المحسن الحربي لقناتي
العربيه والحدث كهرمان مرعش